all right so earlier today against the
advice of everybody here with me in
London well we hit the streets and we
were asking all these protesters to tell
us exactly specifically what they don't
like about President Trump well you
can't make this up take a look why are
you here today I'm here to protest what
specifically don't you like about Ron I
don't like these [ __ ] what policy all
of them tell Tom to go home he's not
welcome here we don't want to be the UK
yeah the TM takes this seriously
but of course he won't know this ignore
it instead hasn't happened Lala this
seems like a party it doesn't seem too
serious don't you love America
people giving you trouble there's no
need for that I think America is divided
like Britain I think part of America is
deeply deeply ashamed and I think pardon
Erica's been hoodwinked you think that
the NATO alliance that the United States
of America is affair if they pay seventy
percent of the bill
what are you protesting are you here to
just you just here to have a party be
honest I can't believe it this turn man
all the hate that Trump exudes yeah I
wasn't gonna come out initially just cuz
Trump's it and why are you here
[Applause]
the nightmare you must be still merica
wake up vote him out it's been what this
summer for a reason you know I mean is
it Donald Trump's for the track
nope I think he's promoting he's
promoting climate change Donald is not
welcome and free Melania that detest
Trump because there's policies because
of his racism and homophobia misogyny
and because he's just two-faced and
dipp'd duplicitous we respect human
rights in this country and we'd like him
to see that the way that he acts in the
way that he speaks we profoundly
profoundly reject it in a polite way the
lies that he's told not to mention the
human rights abuses that he's committed
in his own country we don't think he has
any place
I think a lot of British people are more
intelligent than the Americans are when
it comes to boating because I think that
he represents everything that's toxic
about Western culture and Western
history
[Music]
all right they didn't really have good
reasons but it was kind of a good party
couple I was shocked at how many people
knew me here was reaction the author of
the book why we fight Fox News national
security strategist dr. Sebastian Gorka
retired CIA senior intelligence officer
Fox News contributor Danielle Hoffman
nobody wanted me to go down we have one
little minor little incident but he
didn't get it on tape which drives me
nuts but it wasn't that bad I was
shocked how many people knew me but I
was also they can't answer they just got
mad well should we pay 70% no why are
you protesting uh he's a bad person it's
a reminder every time America shows
strength on the world stage European
socialist liberals hate it if it was
Obama apologizing or dumping 150 billion
on the Mo's they loved it very
reminiscent to me of 1983 when Europeans
came out in protest against President
Reagan for the Pershing to missile
deployment and it's a great contrast and
protect Europe right and President
Reagan was proven right years later we
all agreed it was the right thing to do
of course those protests could never
happen in places like Russia and China
but that's the first point and the
second one we know the Russians have
used there's the social networking and
media sites to try to amplify protests
and hurt our president I just wonder
whether they might have done that in
this case as well I think that's
something for our intelligence community
to check on yeah dr. korkor your your
first reaction we talked off-air you
tell me that you think I'm nuts for even
doing it but what's your reaction yes
they don't have a point which or no
Universal point or nothing specific it's
getting hot in the world is that Trump's
fault
no okay why are you here so I wouldn't
have I would have told you not to do it
but I'm glad you did that was really
very very amusing and very telling at
least we now know that Donald Trump is
responsible for global warming I mean
look these people I would like to see at
least this many Brits
go out and demonstrate against terrorism
go out and demonstrate against the
grooming and rape gangs that are being
prosecuted how about going out and and
demonstrating against female genital
mutilation or the bombing of the area
and a grand a concert in Manchester
these are look we now have proof Sean
snowflakes are everywhere these are not
the people who vote for brexit this is
the chattering classes and they have
nothing to tell you you know the reality
is that but for the United States of
America and our commitment to Europe and
NATO I mean I just they don't survive I
mean now that is the stupidity one of
the I think best things the president
did this week was tell Angela Merkel
stop giving stop creating dependency on
Putin and a hostile regime stop and
we've got more natural resources we
could put more Americans to work with
career jobs tomorrow and export all the
energy they would ever need in all of
you of Western Europe there's a bit of
irony about all of this because Europe
is under greater threat from Russia
today then at any time since the
collapse of the Soviet Union and yes the
United States takes the lead in
countering and deterring 70 plus cents
of every dollar Daniel we pay for NATO
700 billion a year in Germany doesn't
pay their French I mean even beyond the
the financial aspects of this it's
really our moral leadership our
intelligence leadership the strategic
leadership of the United States people
aren't always grateful for that but
again on the eve of the president's
summit with Vladimir Putin I find it
awfully ironic you know the president
said today everything's on the table
with Vladimir Putin and just like the
lead-up to the Kim jong-un summit in
Singapore
oh this is a bad idea the president
shouldn't do this dr. Gorka I think it's
good for the world if the President and
we saw how direct he was with NATO he's
gonna be the same way he can't be any
different that's who he is he it will be
an honest forthright frank discussion
just like it was with little rocket man
and fire and fury
you know the president I know the
president and people always ask me
what's he really like and and the
viewers need to understand he's exactly
the same behind closed doors as he is in
front of 50,000 people in an arena in
Florida he is a straight shooter and you
know when he closes that door and it's
just him and the interpreters he's gonna
say look what you did in the Ukraine is
wrong that it cannot stand stop messing
around in Syria we've already killed two
hundred of your mercenaries and stop
threatening NATO he's going to be a
straight-shooter but look you know rod
Rosen Stein and everybody else wants to
talk about Russian collusion it's a
fantasy mm-hmm as we all know dr. korkor
we wish you were here with us for to see
you as my friend Richard welcome to
London and you see you in Helsinki